Noah Sanders here for the job interview
please take a seat mr. Weinstein we'll
see you next job interviews huh
never fun okay I get it
stay focused awesome big laugh this is
Joe Carroll in that show you know what I
mean
thanks so much for coming in Adam of
course and you better stay away from
that Chinese oh what an absolute delight
it's been great and yeah yeah I don't
even care if I get this job because I
know I've made a friend for life what a
terrific attitude what a great goddamn
attitude yeah you son of a gun you know
what all right quick before you leave I
want to give you something no sir I
can't take any more juice this whole
thing has been a gift
my brother passed away 21 years ago we
were estranged then he became ill and he
gave this to me as a peace offering
and then one day when we were on the
ocean he fell overboard and about very
much like this one and died I saw him
struggling all the way as a riptide just
pulled him down [ __ ] ocean please
accept this as a as a token of my
gratitude for you bringing joy back into
my life under any other circumstance I
would refuse but I will accept this gift
today because I know how much it means
to you
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do you keep a straight face all day
[Applause]
and she's sweet sweeter than fine oh my
god
god damn and I love your [ __ ] energy
well what can I say sir I have
solar-powered
[Music]
really like you like that one huh oh
thanks so much Adam terrific best
interview I've ever been a part of in my
entire life okay who's next you ready
let's go chop chop
here we go come on let's go okay
requesting permission just come on board
sir I know what Sanders his name sorry
to hear about your brother maybe we need
some Chinese food after this all right
all right
okay take it easy geez settle down turbo
[Music]
you